kim kardashian and pete davidson are
sneaking in some quality time we're
talking private jets
and vacay people i love that a source
tells et that kim and pete who we're
officially calling keat are on vacation
spending time together at the end of the
day life is about being happy
quote the two weren't able to ring in
the new year since she was with her
family in california and pete was
hosting his new year's eve special in
miami here we are in the place for a new
year's show miami with my league is
lauren said so e.t source says that the
two know they have a busy couple of
months coming up kim is in the middle of
rebranding her companies while pete is
filming a couple of different projects
so they wanted to take in some time away
before the year ramps up it's really lit
and fun and crazy paparazzi snapped the
duo boarding a plane on monday
reportedly bound for the bahamas look
closely and you'll see kim stepping
through the cabin door for their lovers
getaway and that right there hopping out
of the car
that's pete it's always so much fun
while we anxiously await what are sure
to be some fire instagrams from this
getaway will kill time by reliving some
epic new year's eve moments from pete
and kim's famous fam while pete was busy
hosting his tv special with miley cyrus
on nbc miley's going to be performing
some of her favorite songs tonight
and i'll be here also kim's mom kris
jenner was a virtual guest on andy cohen
and anderson cooper's new year's eve
special on cnn
you know everyone is talking about kim's
new relationship with pete davidson if
you had the chance to spend time with
them how are they as a couple you're
always digging in yes i am during her
appearance andy didn't shy away from
asking the family matriarch about her
daughter's budding romance
but in true boss mom fashion she
sidestepped his question with a little
help from kylie jenner's three-year-old
daughter stormy
that's a little stormy um
hey stormy oh
um you sit right here um yeah
nice distraction good timing stormy
perfect
right on you
kris jenner thank you so much have a
great new year and chris isn't the only
one to stay tight-lipped about their
love when eti chatted with the comedian
saturday night live co-star alex moffitt
he played coy when asked about the
couple
i don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend uh pete's up to i just
hope he's vaccinated as long as he's
having fun and he's happy that's all i
care about he's a love then there's
machine gun kelly who's good pals with
pete gotta ask you your boy pete
davidson and kim kardashian how happy
are you for him
but we're happy yeah yeah
but back to kim and pete's getaway yes
the trip appears to be the first real
vacation for the couple who first
sparked romance rumors back in october
after kim's hosting gig on snl
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not i sure
am jasmine
and a source previously told et that the
two are dating and having a great time
together quote pete is a romantic and
goes out of his way to make kim feel
special
kim thinks pete is hysterical and he's
constantly making her laugh but they
also have been connecting on a deeper
level
[Music]
you